كانت اول زياره دوله البريطانيا لرئيس
روسي منذ عام
1874 في يونيو حزيران 2003
وليس مبالغ القول ان التوتر هيمنه على
العلاقات الروسيه البريطانيه في غالبيه
مراحل التاريخ الحديث
روسيا تنظر لبريطانيا بعين الريبه
وتعتبرها دوله عدائيه وبريطانيا تتهم
الكرملين بتصميم معارضين روس على اراضيها
وتشكك في ديمقراطيه النظام الروسي
كان هناك تدهور مستدام احيانا يكون حادا
لناحيه طبيعه العلاقه التي اراد بوتين
لروسيا ان تقيمها معنا وما رايناه في
السنوات الاخيره تزايد القمع الداخلي لكن
ايضا العدوانيه الخارجيه وهذان الامران
يسيران معا وهو ما لم نريده في السنوات
الاخيره صار واضحا بشكل متزايد ان
مقاربتنا ومقاربه الغرب يجب ان تتغير في
بدايه العام الفين كان كل شيء طبيعيا لكن
كلما اصبحت روسيا اكثر قوه بدا انها تشكل
تهديدا للهيمنه البريطانيه الامريكيه في
العالم بدات تغيير حوالي العام 2013 عندما
بدات الاتهامات غير المسنوده بادله
ذلك الوقت بدات العلاقات بالتدهور السريع
ثم جاءت القرم والميدان والميدان كان نوعا
من الثوره لان الرئيس اطاحت به الدول
الغربيه نطلق عليها اسم عمليه خاصه لكنها
حرب وقد بدات بالفعل عام 2014
واتخذت العلاقات منعطفا خطيرا لحظه بدء
عمليه العسكريه روسيا في اوكرانيا
بريطانيا خرجت من الاتحاد الاوروبي وتريد
اعطاء مظهر قوه فتصدرت مواجهه الكرملين
ناهيك عن ان الحرب الروسيه هي على القاره
الاوروبيه
النقطه التي يجب ان نخلص اليها ان العلاقه
الحاليه مع روسيا ليست العلاقه التي
نريدها لكنها العلاقه التي لدينا لذا ما
تعبنا من فعله هو ما حاولت الحكومات
المتعاقبه فعله خلال السنوات الاخيره وهو
العمل مع روسيا حيث نستطيع العمل معها حين
يكون ذلك في مصلحتنا وحيث يجب علينا ان
ندفع بعيدا الامور التي تهدد العلاقه
اعتقد ان ما يجري في السنوات الاخيره
الماضيه ان التحديات لامننا من الكريم
صارت حاده جدا ولم يعد من الممكن بعد الان
التفكير على قاعده التعاون ولكن
لن ناخذ ليست فكرتنا نحن لا نريد هدم
العلاقه لكنني اؤمن اننا سنبقى جيرانا في
القاره نفسها روسيا بالطبع لن تختفي روسيا
ستنتصر في هذا النزاع راشد كورس
الاوكرانيه لعداء قديم وعميق يتخذ شكل حرب
غير مباشره والنتيجه واحده العلاقات
البريطانيه الروسيه سيئه حتى اشعار اخر من
لندن لما مكتبي العربيه